[Musique]
bienvenue à ce thème dagnas une prison
deadman tonnes conçu pour les criminels
autochtone la plus grande du genre au
pays on compte ici 73 détenus et
gestionnaires et la majorité du
personnel aussi sont autochtones
[Musique]
y a pas de barrière ici entre gardiens
prisonniers sait où la commis un meurtre
il est derrière les barreaux depuis dix
ans avant d'arriver ici il a passé des
années dans le système carcéral pour la
première fois à ce thème daniel on se
traite avec respect maintenant je ne
suis plus antisociale je peux parler à
quelqu'un en le regardant dans les yeux
je souris tu suis même capable de
rigoler pour être admis ici et détenus
doivent s'engager à renouer avec leur
culture autochtone nous nous attendons à
ce qu'il prenne part par exemple à une
cérémonie traditionnelle une fois par
semaine ou à une rencontre avec un aîné
autochtone pour discuter de leurs
difficultés à sa manière on met l'accent
sur la guérison non sur la punition
ajoute la directrice
mais il y a plus et détenus ont
davantage de liberté que dans une prison
conventionnel
[Musique]
ne sont jamais enfermés dans leur
chambre ils peuvent même appeler leurs
proches quand ils le veulent c'est un
détenu de s'enfuir personne ne leur sied
et la police est alertée et il ne peut
pas réintégré l'établissement
on n'a pas l'impression d'être observé
au microscope
ça donne le sentiment d'un capable de
travailler sur nous mais d'accueillir
des auteurs de crimes graves dans des
centres qui offrent autant de liberté le
mois dernier une femme autochtone qui a
été reconnu coupable d'avoir tué une
fillette de huit ans a été transféré
dans un établissement du genre une
démarche et responsables disent les
conservateurs mais selon le gouvernement
trudeau il n'y a pas lieu de s'inquiéter
le processus d'admission est extrêmement
rigoureux
ce ne sont pas tous les détenus qui
peuvent y entrer les femmes que nous
acceptons présente un risque très faible
de récidive
ici elle s'échappe c'est peu probable
qu'elle s'en prenne à quelqu'un vers qui
aucun foot est la directrice générale du
centre de guérison pour samedi ne
m'étonne elle et son équipe ont
sélectionné au peigne fin les 28
résidente de l'établissement comme sept
détenus condamnés pour meurtre j'ai
passé environ la moitié de ma vie en
prison et je sais que c'est l'endroit
qui va me permettre de retourner à la
maison
[Musique]
les détenus comme ces femmes qui ont
complété une thérapie dans un pavillon
de ressourcement ont un taux de récits
des deux seulement 6 % en moyenne
nationale est presque le double à 11
pour ça c'est clair pour moi que si vous
traitez les gens convenablement que vous
leur apprenez à renouer avec leurs
racines leur famille à se trouver un
emploi bien ils sont beaucoup moins
enclins à récidiver que si vous voulez
laisser dans une cellule jusqu'à la fin
de leur peine pour elle comme pour de
nombreuses femmes qui sont passés par
ici
ce genre de centre c'est un modèle à
imiter s'il y avait plus d'endroits
comme offre au cdj je pense que ça
aiderait beaucoup d'hommes et femmes
autochtones
une façon de briser le cycle de
traumatismes et de souffrance qui se
transmet d'une génération à une autre et
c'est marie pierre mercier radio canada
[Musique]